you may know goldman sachs is a huge
investment firm for the rich and have
probably seen them here and there on the
news but what exactly is goldman sachs
and how do they go from investing to the
rich to investing for the average person
make sure to stick around till the end
to find out
[Music]
welcome to hobbies so here's just some
quick history on there groups of the
company Marcus Goldman was a Bavarian
teacher who emigrated to the United
States in 1848 he then established
common sacks in 1869 his son-in-law
Samuel sax joined the company in 1882
and soon enough
Marcus's son Henry and his son-in-law
Ludwig joined the company in 1885
Goldman Sachs became one of the first
firms to offer entrepreneurs with
commercial paper financing and the
company joined the New York Stock
Exchange in 1896 the company was growing
rapidly and just in two years time the
company had garnered over 1.6 million
dollars in capital in 1906 the company
issued its first IPO in which it took
sears and roebuck of a public later on
they also helped FW Woolworth and
Continental can go public
over the years after several
acquisitions and expansions Goldman
Sachs and established itself as a market
leader in the financial industry the
company launched Goldman Sachs treating
corporate 1928 as a close and fun but
this quickly filled just the next year
in 1929 stock market crash despite these
major setbacks Goldman Sachs continued
to grow and as to others their first
international office in London in 1970
it even created a private wealth and
fixed income division in 1972 to further
reach in the United Kingdom in 1981 they
acquired Jay Aaron and company which
mainly Delta coffee
metals and foreign exchange this was a
crucial acquisition for Goldman Sachs as
it helped him tap into the South
American market and spur
growth years later in 1986 they
established goldman sachs asset
management which they copy that to this
day manages their mutual hedge funds
there are four major branches that make
up goldman sachs the first two of which
are investment banking and investment
managing the investment banking division
accounted for 21% of all goldman sachs
revenue in 2015
financial advisory involves advisory
assignments on mergers and acquisitions
restructuring corporate defense
activities risk management and
derivative transactions related to these
advisory assignments goldman sachs
offers public offerings and private
placements including local and global
transactions the company gained a lot of
Fame in 1980s for advising how to avoid
forced hostile takeovers then investment
management segments other hand
accounting for 18% of the total revenue
in 2015 it provides an investment
advisory and financial planning services
along with investment products such as
equity of fixed income that are spread
across all major asset classes these
products are offered through separately
managed accounts private partnerships
mutual funds and other structures the
financial planning services included
trusts and estate planning charity
donations tax planning and income
management however the bulk of the
revenue in this segment comes with
transaction management fees the
investing and lending segments accounted
for 16% of all of a Goldman Sachs
revenue in 2015 this involves long term
investing and lending across a variety
of assets some of which include debt
securities loans real estate and private
and public every securities Goldman
Sachs is able to directly invest into
public and private equities through his
investment funds or through third-party
managed funds it provides financing to
its corporate individual customers
through bank loans
mortgage-backed securities and personal
loans the institutional clients segment
comprised of about 45% of their total
revenue in 2015 but this quickly
decreased to just 18% in just two years
in 2017 the client services that are
provided are based on us
class it includes client acquisition
activities in both cash and derivative
products for interest rate products
credit products mortgages currencies and
commodities interest rate products
include things such as government bonds
and repurchase agreements the credit
products include things such as
corporate securities and credit
derivatives mortgage includes mortgage
backed loans securities and derivatives
or other assets based loans securities
and derivatives and finally commodities
include commodity derivatives and
sometimes can include physical purses
petroleum products and metals in the end
Goldman Sachs one of the most well known
and reputable investment firms on Wall
Street however one of their biggest
setbacks today is a 2008 recession
Goldman Sachs was one of the firm's I
incur massive losses during 2008 because
a lot of your assets were mortgage
backed securities as a result when the
housing bubble burst goldman sachs faced
financial disaster the US Treasury
actually bailed a mouth as if it in a
troubled asset relief program in 2008
the US Treasury invested ten billion
dollars into Goldman Sachs Goldman
repaid the investment with the 23%
interest in the form of 318 million in
preferred dividends and one point four
one eight billion a warrant Redemption
the issue was that from 2005 in 2007
Goldman Sachs issued a lot of mortgages
and securities to a lot of people we had
shoddy credit scores this was clearly
not a smart choice and eventually when
the Hasegawa burst has led to hundreds
of foreclosures and significant losses
and of course that in turn led to
billions of dollars in losses for
investors the final settlement
mentioned mortgages that originated from
countrywide Vermont and other companies
countrywide was later acquired by Bank
of America 2008 and from want is no
longer in business this blunter mistake
was clearly not going to be forgiven and
as a result Goldman Sachs had to pay two
point three nine billion dollars in
civil penalties
and on top of that they had to pay a 1.8
billion dollars in relief in the form of
loan forgiveness and financing for
affordable housing an additional eight
hundred and seventy five million dollars
was ordered to be paid in cash but other
state and federal entities to make
matters even worse the new york-based
Goldman Sachs had to agree to a list of
facts that destroyed the reputation they
had to agree they misled investors on
mortgage backed securities
creating a false view of how risky the
investment actually was they also had to
agree that the bank failed to do its due
diligence just three years ago in
January of 2016
Goldman Sachs reveal they had to pay
five billion dollars or government in
relation to their role in the financial
crisis as it is clear the effectiveness
financial crisis are still very
prescient in Goldman Sachs even today
and even all of those are just some of
the times the Goldman Sachs had to pay
off huge reparations in 2010 the bank
had to pay five hundred fifty million
dollars to security and Exchange
Commission's from misleading investors
it paid the fine but neither accepted or
denied the charges and then in 2014 they
had paid three billion dollars to the
federal plants housing agency to settle
claim that Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
there are also several other private
claims Adams filed against Goldman Sachs
and this wasn't the fate of just Goldman
Sachs as Goldman Sachs was the fifth
bank to reach a multi billion dollar
settlement the Department of Justice in
relation to subprime mortgages during
the Great Recession
along with JPMorgan Chase Bank of
America Citigroup and Morgan Stanley as
it is evident after the financial crisis
the reputation of the company took a
beating and this resulted in one the
greatest pivots of Wall Street history
so how exactly did Goldman Sachs make
the transition from investing for the
rich to investing for the average well
for starters they became much more
consumer-friendly
weren't the biggest strides into
consumer market is the launches their
banking app market to 2016 which was
named after a founder Marcus Goldman the
business offers personal
unsecured loans of up to $30,000 there
are targeting
consumers who are looking to pay off
their credit card debt or just are fed
up with other banking systems the Marcus
platform offers loans for two to six
years from five point nine percent to
twenty two point nine percent APR the
lack of origination and prepayment dates
flexible payment dates and overall
simplicity makes a lot more consumer
friendly than other banking apps
consumer finance is relatively new
territory for Goldman Sachs but they are
confident that their knowledge and risk
management technologies will help them
dominate means to finance this is
especially true and Goldman Sachs
actually gains an advantage as most of
your competitors are also going through
huge transition right now to digital
platforms and new lending models such as
marketplace loans furthermore Goldman
Sachs is making strategic entry into
your consumer market through Apple the
partnership was announced just a couple
of months ago and this new partnership
will of place apples all the partnership
with Barclays the deal is also structure
a bit differently as common stock will
have to pay Apple a fee for every sub
consumer card as issued with the
Barclays Apple waived is fee in favor of
interest-free financing this is perfect
for Goldman Sachs as they are able to
directly enter market where a lot of
consumers take on consumer debt to buy
Apple products this is also perfect for
a class they will be able to diversify
their revenue streams as your iPhone
sales are stagnating furthermore
executives hope that this will encourage
people to use Apple pay Apple already
receives it cost of payment when you pay
using Apple pay but they're expecting to
make even more money when you use Apple
pay and use your own credit card to pay
for it unfortunately Goldman Sachs lost
include amount of reputation during the
2008 economic recession as a result they
turned over into the mainstream market
while using Apple and Marcus other
vehicles into the market this combined
with their intense knowledge in the
finance industry has allowed them to
excel in their consumer market as well
and sustain rapid growth and that is why
Goldman Sachs has recently become more
consumer oriented and how exactly they
made that transition over the last 150
years they've gained a lot of experience
and while they got hit or during the
economic recession of 2008 everybody
pretty well
whether you're fond of banks or you
think that they're all evil you can bet
that Goldman Sachs will be around for
quite a while but that's why I have for
you guys having goldman sachs brings
your comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like severe the major drop a like
and consider subscribing if you're going
to see more videos just like this one
but till then I'm Hari I'll see you guys
on next
you